when do you decide uh when you're gonna
dye your hair for the fight my girl does
my hair she loves like she loves doing
my hair she she does hair for a living
so she's always kind of like playing
with different hair so whatever you want
go ahead pretty much i'm like whatever
you think is gonna look sweet like i
think we're gonna do like this color
with a pink
color yeah the rainbow was fine
that was the first one that was like six
nine inspired too like that was right
the first time i did it and that was
that was i asked six when the first time
he he uh saw me was and he said that
fight someone's like hey this kid's got
the same hair
uh and that was the first time he he had
saw me fight and then knocked out eddie
which is pretty cool yeah the hair is
[ __ ] fun to play around with it's
just like
we got to be different in the sport i
mean you've done such a good job of
having like a name and a brand and like
being this celebrity within the sport
was that at all intentional or are you
just kind of like that kind of guy
yeah but i wanted to be
when i was young young in montana like i
wanted to be in the nfl like when i was
delusional and you didn't i didn't
understand i wasn't going to be six poor
like i want to be in the nfl and i'm
like okay that's not going to happen i
want to be famous how am i going to do
that i don't [ __ ] know i don't have
any like crazy skills and i found
fighting and i was like oh maybe i can
just put on performances that way and it
kind of like built like that and then
seeing connor
blow up like two years before
two or three years before i went pro i'm
like oh [ __ ] like i kind of had that
vision for myself like i wanted to
transcend the sport and like be that guy
and then conor did it before me so now i
know what to not do because connor's
kind of going crazy a little bit so it's
like kind of like uh yeah it's
making it really difficult to like him
i know i'll always look at conor's
connor knocked out although in 13
seconds beat eddie alvarez like
just sure but yeah i mean yeah it's who
knows where his head's at
and then leg kicks changed the game yeah
i mean that one it was weird because
before that watching the embeddeds
watching his like the videos he was
putting out before that fight i remember
seeing him like get do his sessions and
then go sit in his chair and then put
his ank his ankle in the ice bath and i
was like damn i wonder if he's dealing
with ankle shin some some kind of injury
and he sure as [ __ ] he said is like she
was it was already [ __ ] up but dude
that's what happened sparring is where
you get your injuries dude like
it's just part of the sport you want a
lot some people's
you i i have to spar and in camp i spar
out of camp i don't in camp i gotta spar
make sure you know that's where you
that's where you can get your confidence
from where you know your cardio is that
where you can trust your trust the work
that's been put in is is paying off but
also deal comes with injuries like
he injured that in sparring and then
it's part of the you know what happened
what happened in the fight
yeah dude
thanks for watching that clip and if you
live in america there's a good chance
that this big badass tour bus is coming
to your town with my bucket list tour
what is it well it's an x-rated show
full of all the stuff that i would have
never been allowed to do for jackass and
a lot of it is flagrantly illegal so
it's adults only and if you live in any
of these states then you better go to
stevo.com and check out my tour schedule
hurry up and get your tickets too
because it's selling out everywhere
yeah dude
[Music]
yeah dude